effectivement pour les bloquistes un
sondage qui est une mauvaise nouvelle
j'ai duceppe 16% des intentions de vote
c'est vrai qu'on est encore loin de
jours de vote mais il ya toute une côte
à remonter et julie dufresne a concentré
son effort là-dessus aujourd'hui pour
voir un peu où en est le bloc québécois
en déposant son bulletin de candidature
gilles duceppe affiche un sourire de
circonstance mais l' enthousiasme ne
repose certainement pas sur le dernier
coup de sonde
une fois qu'on a pédalé face aux vins
le restant de la route on a le vent dans
le dos dans la circonscription de
laurier sainte marie où il se présente
les grands partis ont commencé à
s'afficher
il ne cherchait pas une pancarte chef du
bloc québécois
elles n'apparaîtront que dans quelques
semaines ok pour l'heure c'est en grande
partie sur le parti faire que semblent
comptés le bloc gilles duceppe multiplié
les apparitions avec le nouveau chef du
parti québécois et ses députés
il ya les ordres ça me fait très plaisir
s'ajuster l'ailé la la campagne ça
dérape c'est le blog qu'il a fait ce
qu'on fait c'est ont donc l'appui vous
voulez une information vous voulez vous
voulez connaître déjà rencontré des gens
bien moi je suis là je suis là parce que
je crois encore profondément s'il faut
que québec devienne un pays il faut dire
que le bloc a bien besoin de tout pousse
alors la dissolution de la chambre
ils n'étaient plus que deux députés et à
part le chef et le président du parti
il n'y a que très peu de visages connus
parmi les candidats parfois même pas de
photo sur le site web de celui qui
portera les couleurs du parti
on est loin des années fastes du parti
fondé par lucien bouchard comme ici en
2008 49 bloquistes qui était envoyé au
parlement l'année
oui vous avez donc voté oui en cas d'un
oui j'ai voiture à celle nollet fait
partie de ceux qui les avaient été lus à
l'époque et en 2015
elle veut surtout s'assurer que les
conservateurs ne soit pas reporté au
pouvoir
pour elle le changement doit passer par
le npd judiciaire je trouve ben et
belfort
son terme si gilles duceppe a dit voir
un renouveau du cycle politique avec
l'arrivée de pierre karl péladeau ce
politologue et prédit plutôt une
nouvelle tendance
et comme si au niveau fédéral les
beaucoup de gens qui délaisse le clivage
naturelle depuis plusieurs années qu'ils
étaient entre les oui et les non au
projet d'indépendance en queue du québec
vers un débat qui est davantage orientée
sur la gauche et la droite pour rod
herbert quand on est ministre sous
jacques parizeau vitro on va relever les
manches mais c'est pratiquement un cri
du coeur
à l'heure actuelle je dis ça mais j'en
profite pour dire j'espère que tous les
jeunes qui sont souvent on espère qu'ils
vont s'impliquer dans cette campagne non
c'est trop important pour la suite des
jours ils déjà le chef du parti
québécois diminue les attentes
il faut pas nécessairement conclure que
le résultat des élections est un
résultat définitif pour le mouvement
souverainiste gilles duceppe insiste
tout de même selon lui les
souverainistes doivent faire front
commun sur la scène fédérale
il invite d'ailleurs les militants
d'option nationale et de québec
solidaire à unir leurs voix et à voter
pour le bloc ici julie dufresne radio
canada québec